les déclarations du mari sur l'état
dépressif de son épouse sont en décalage
complet avec ce sourire éclatant que
Véronique pyoton arborait sur les
photos alors que s'est-il vraiment passé
dans la chambre 602 de l'hôtel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mondo 30 octobre 2013 il est
22h55 à l'hôtel Mo
en Belgique la soirée est
calme en
[Musique]
apparence car un client de l'hôtel
surgit affolé dans le hall c'est le
locataire de la chambre 602 j'ai dévalé
les escaliers plutôt que prendre
l'ascenseur j'ai appelé disant voilà
monous je crois qu'elle s'est suicidée
ils ont d'abord cru que c'était une
blague parce que c'est éta la soirée
d'Halloween Bernard Westfall n'est pas
du genre à plaisanter c'est un homme
politique belge de 55 ans et il pense
sérieusement que sa femme s'est
suicidée alors le réceptionniste le suit
jusqu'à sa chambre et découvre une scène
d'horreur dans la salle de main on
retrouve le corps d'une femme allongée
sur le
sol
elle est inerte elle ne bouge plus et à
côté d'elle un petit sac en
plastique l'épouse du parlementaire a
gardé son nom de jeune fille elle
s'appelle Véronique Piroton elle a 42
ans le réceptionniste appelle les
secours et essaie de savoir si elle
respire
encore il met GSM devant la bouche de
mon épouse il y a plus de
de buer sur le GSM et donc ça veut dire
qu'il ne respire plus donc il faut faire
le tout pour le tout pour la
sauver alors en attendant les secours le
réceptionniste tente de réanimer
Véronique
Piroton chaque seconde
[Musique]
compte c'était une relation qui part
après devenu malsine
elle s'est rendu compte qu'il n'était
pas l'homme qu'elle pensait elle a été
très déçu de
lui il découvre que Véronique Piroton
avait une aventure
extraconjugale malheureusement Véronique
Piroton n'est pas morte toute seule
j'entendre des pleurs de femmes des cris
de femmes femme qui crie comme un
lou non je n'ai pas tué Véronique
Poton arrivé sur place la chef
urgentiste tente un massage cardiaque
pour réanimer Véronique
Piroton je suis en train de prier pour
qu'elle revienne je prie dans l'absolu
pour qu'elle revienne à la vie je suis
très très mal le policier qui s'occupe
de
moi me dit c'est c'est trop long
monsieur westfal ça dure trop
[Musique]
longtemps
et elle va s'acharner pendant une
vingtaine de minutes avec des autres
secouristes pour essayer de la faire
revenir à la vie mais elle n'y arrivera
pas à
23h35 les secoristes ne peuvent que
constater le décès de Véronique
[Musique]
Piroton c'est la fin de
tout c'est là que je me suis
complètement effondré
oui pour Bernard Westfall le choc est
immense Véronique Piroton était son
grand
amour c'était une femme resplendissante
elle avait de la classe du talent
intellectuellement elle cuisinait
superériement bien elle savait recevoir
elle elle avait
tout Véronique était une femme vraiment
amoureuse de la littérature elle lisait
énormément elle était cultivée
c'était vraiment une femme
extraordinaire pour
moi Bernard et Véronique se rencontre en
mai
2012 et cette relation démarre presque
sur un
malentendu nous étions dans le même bar
une sorte de taverne sous les hauteurs
de Liège un ami est arrivé et j'ai lui
dit en boutâ comme cela je te présente
ma nouvelle compagne et cet ami m'a dit
enfin je la connais même pas c'était un
très bon ami je la connais même pas et
Véronique et moi on s'est regarder et je
lui ai dit tu vas voir et on s'est
embrassé
spontanément et depuis là on n pas
arrêté de de se voir de
s'aimer 3 mois plus tard le couple se
marie en
Toscane
[Musique]
quand elle s'est mariée elle était
enchantée j'ai toujours un message
d'ailleurs un sms qu'elle m'a envoyé le
jour de son mariage elle était c'était
le jour J donc elle était très
content seulement le bonheur aurait été
de courte durée la belle histoire de
Bernard et Véronique s'arrête
tragiquement dans cette chambre
[Musique]
d'hôtel alors pour pourquoi la
quadragéire aurait-elle décidé de mettre
fin à ses jours alors qu'elle nageait en
plein
bonheur lorsque la police d'ustand
arrive sur les lieux Bernard Westfall
répète inlassablement que sa femme s'est
[Musique]
suicidée Bernard Westfall affirme que sa
femme s'est suicidée et d'ailleurs il en
veut pour preuve qu'elle avait un sac
plastique sur la tête et qu'elle s'est
suicidé par asphyie
le sachet de plastique est découvert
près de sa
tête Bernard wal dira qu'il l'a trouvé
avec le sachet de plastique à moitié
collé sur le visage et qu'il l'a
lui-même
[Musique]
ôté dans un premier temps tout laissent
penser que Véronique Piroton s'est donné
la mort en plus du sac plastique des
emballages d'antidépresseur et
d'anxiolitique sont retrouvés éparpillés
dans la chambre et dans la salle de
bain seulement à y regarder de plus près
les enquêteurs découvrent plusieurs
éléments qui clochent à commencer par le
désordre qui règne dans la chambre du
couple un peu comme si une dispute avait
[Applaudissements]
éclaté il y a une bouteille de vin qui
est entamé qui se trouve s un meuble il
y a un gobelet de vin qui manifestement
été renversé sur le sol
il y a un autre gobelet dans lequel il
reste un fond de
[Musique]
vin la médecin urgentiste a elle aussi
des doutes sur la thèse du suicide
avancé par le mari
elle va constater qu'il y a une trace de
pression au niveau du cou et elle va
constater des traces au niveau de cou
aux jambes également une trace au niveau
du nez pour ce médecin la mort de cette
femme n'est pas n'est pas
naturel à ce stade une question traverse
les esprits une dispute aurait-elle
éclaté dans la chambre Bernard westfal
serait-il pour quelque chose dans la
mort de son
épouse pour y voir plus clair le corps
de Véronique Piroton est emmené à la
morgue pour y être
autopsié
à quelques centaines de kilomètres de là
à Liège sa famille est prévenue du drame
qui vient de se
produire je l'ai appris par ma cousine
qui m'a
téléphoné à 5h3 du matin pour me dire
que V
décédé c'est évidemment donc un choc
c'est surtout le choc par rapport à
Victor puisque donc Victor dormait
encore à ce moment-là puis donc était 6h
du matin c'est logique et c'était
surtout ça le choc comment ce qu'on
allait lui annoncer
cela Victor c'est le fils de Véronique
Piroton qu'elle a eu d'un précédent
mariage il avait 14 ans au moment des
faits Victor donc
c'est s'est mis à hurler c'est logique
c'est normal et c'était le le moment le
plus dur de ma vie
h dire en effet Victor que c'est moment
donc n'était plus d'autant plus que ce
qui était plus dur c'est
que je ne savais pas lui expliquer
comment puisque donc on neous le disait
pas et ni dans quelles circonstances
tout ce que je savais c'est que c'était
à a
stand Bernard Westfall seul témoin de la
soirée est donc le premier à être
entendu par les
policiers et le mari n'en démore pas son
épouse s'est donné la
mort d'ailleurs il va livrer de nouveaux
éléments concernant la personnalité de
Véronique des éléments loin d'être
anodin dans les dernières années
Véronique Poton a commis plusieurs
tentatives de suicide jusqu'à se jeter
dans la Meuse devant sa mère
elle a été sauvée par un passant qui a
eu le courage de se jeter dans l'eau du
fleuve en fait c'était plutôt des appels
à l'aide et quelqu'un qui veut suicider
va le faire de façon très discrète et
ces tentativ de suicide n'ont jamais été
donc discrè enfin quand vous sautez en
robe de nuit dans la Meuse avec un verre
dans nez même si vous êtes bon nageuse
il y a des fortes chances quand même que
vous y restiez et c'est un passant
maître nageur qui l'a sauvé je vous
donne pas les détails des autres
tentatives de suicide c'était plus que
des des aspect au secours c'était un
malêtre un malaise
profond mais ce n'est pas tout d'autres
éléments donnés par le mari montre que
Véronique Piroton souffrait d'une
importante
dépression on découvre surtout que elle
consomme régulièrement de l'alcool
qu'elle consomme également des produits
des médicaments
antidépresseurs elle a un traitement et
elle le prend de façon un petit peu
le problème c'est qu'elle ne supporte
pas beaucoup l'alcool donc c'està-dire
qu'après de TR he elle pouvait très vite
êtreché mais c'est certain on le sait
bien que médicaments et alcool font
mauvais
ménage j'ai vu parfois mon épouse
rentrer dans un état de délabement
physique tel que je me disais mais
pourquoi et souvent nous l'attendions
elle ne rentrait pas
ou elle rentrait à 9h elle titubait dans
l'escalier combien de fois on a dû
l'aider à monter les escaliers au 3è
étage sur lesqueles elle tombais
régulièrement où elle se faisait
mal les déclarations du mari sur l'état
dépressif de son épouse sont en décalage
complet avec ce sourire éclatant que
Véronique Piroton arborait sur les
photos alors que s'est-il vraiment passé
dans la chambre 602 de l'hôtel
mondo l'autopsie du corps de la victime
va peut-être apporter une
[Musique]
réponse à l'institut médico-légal de
Bruges les médecins légistes rendent
leur rapport le soir du drame Véronique
Piroton avait effectivement bu
énormément d'alcool et pris des
antidépresseurs on sait queonique
Piroton mon destin av UNEC plus de 3 g
d'alcool dans le sang ce qui est
évidemment une alcoolmie extrêmement
élevée et il fallait ajouter à cela un
taux extrêmement important de plusieurs
maisonsazépine nétait pas au niveau des
doses létales mais on éta des doses qui
éta des doses extrêmement
toxiques mais pour les experts l'excès
d'alcool et de médicament n'a pas pu
causer la mort de Véronique
Piroton ils sont formelle
elle ne s'est pas
suicidé selon eux vernique pereton est
décédé d'un étouffement qui est provoqué
par un
tiers l'ensemble des conclusions indique
que la mort par asphyxie a été
occasionnée par un tiers et correspond à
une
[Musique]
strangulation et ce n'est pas tout
Véronique Piroton aurait aussi été
battu il parle d'abord de 30
3 lion don certain
puisque le FO saign puisque la rate sa
parce que il yussi des contusions
pulmonaire il y avait des traces que les
médecins lgrib
cou nous avons également constaté que
cette violence avait été accompagné ou
précédé par des violences contendante
brutale sur la
tête boî crâenne massif
nasal
en clair avant de mourir Véronique
Piroton aurait été violemment
frappée le parquet de Brugge est
immédiatement saisi pour
meurtre Bernard westfal est placé en
garde à
vue les enquêteurs quant à eux
poursuivent leurs investigations et
découvre que le couple avait de sérieux
problèmes
d'argent Véronique Piroton se plaignait
d'ailleurs de ce que Bernard Westfall ne
participait pas au frais du ménage
n'intervenait en rien dans les frais de
logement n'intervenait en rien dans les
frais liés tout simplement à aux achats
de tous les jours pour subsister dans
les magasins c'était une des
récriminations de Véronique peroton à
l'gard de Bernard westfal mais la vérité
c'est que je renfouis tout le temps son
compte parce que à partir de 14 moi
n'ait plus d'argent sur son compte
tantôt 500 € 1000 € 2000 € 3000 € euh
très
régulièrement c'est ça alors qu'elle
avait elle-même un bon
salaire en réalité ces dernières
semaines Véronique et Bernard
traversaient une grave crise
conjugale ce sont les proches qui vont
le révéler aux enquêteur
elle s'est rendu compte qu'il n'était
pas l'homme qu'elle pensait
elle a été très déçue de
lui je l'ai rencontré donc un jour donc
malheureusement ça n'allait pas du tout
et puis donc je l'ai vu et je lui ai
demandé ce qui séit passé et puis elle
m'a commencé à me parler que qu'elle
était déchantée donc par rapport à son
mariage qu'elle voulait donc divorcer
que Bernard W n'était pas l'homme idéal
qu'elle attendait et puis qu' avait plus
vraiment du moins de son côté plus
d'amour donc il
voulait marquer une séparation et ne
plus être avec lui
en fouillant la vie de la quadragénaire
les enquêteurs vont faire une découverte
plus que
troublante qui pourrait bien indiquer
que Véronique Piroton voulait quitter
son mari il découvre que Véronique
Piroton avait une aventure
extraconjugale elle trompait Bernard
westfal avec son ex
compagnon en fait Véronique a renoué
avec son ancien petit ami
Oswald et cela ne date pas d'hier car à
peine venait-elle de se marier avec
Bernard westfal qu'elle retournait dans
les bras de son
ex on saveit également que il laessait
de la reconquérir qu'il y a eu des
contacts qui ont perduré malgré le
mariage de de Véronique avec
bernardfal et que finalement ces
contacts tentative de reprise de contact
ont abouti à une reprise de leur
relation assez rapidement après le
mariage alors pour les enquêteurs une
question se pose une question qui
pourrait bient toutt
[Musique]
changer Bernard westfal était-il au
courant de la liaison de sa femme avec
Oswald si on arrive à établir que le
couple va pas bien si on arrive va
établir que cette femme trompe son mari
et que le mari le sait c'est peut-être
un mobile pour que le mari a envie de
tuer la femme or c'est ça qu'il cherche
les enquêteurs il cherch le
mobile il me paraît que la prise de
connaissance par Perin West de son
infortune a été une des bases de
l'enquête et une des causes qui a fait
que l'enquête s'est orienté vers le
missde
volontaire mais face à la juge
d'instruction Bernard les formel il
ignorait tout de la double vie de son
épouse mais j'ai un minimum d'orgueil si
vous voulez hein et donc si j'avais su
cela pensez-vous que je serais resté
c'est pas une question de matisme ou de
euh mais il y a un minimum de respect de
soi même si c'est pas de l'orgueil c'est
du respect de soi Bernard évidemment
n'est pas quelqu'un qui va se s'en
[__] complètement que la personne qui
l'aime puisse le tromper puisse se
retrouver dans les bras de quelqu'un
d'autre ça c'est c'est c'est très
clair il va prétendre que il ne savait
rien du tout et que c'est par le dossier
qu'il a appris la relation de Véronique
Piroton et d'Oswald ce qui est contredit
par par une série d'éléments du dossier
notamment par le fait que à un moment
donné il va révéler avoir eu
connaissance d'une lettre parfumée et
envoyée à Véronique Piroton l'homme
politique vient de se contredire face
aux enquêteurs il admet avoir découvert
l'existence de cette lettre parfumée
quelqu semaine après son mariage avec
Véronique
Piroton ce courrier est signé par
Roswald et son contenu et pour le moin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
explicite Bernard wesfal a accepté face
à notre caméra de raconter comment ce
jour-là il a mis son épouse
pied du
M qu'est-ce qu'il dit dans cette lettre
il raconte le dernier rapport amourux
dans des
détails sur lequel je vais pas
m'étendre je suis bouleversé il a
quelques Moison est
ensemble épous bien qu'il se passe
quelque chose je dis
voilà l cette lettre si tu me confirmes
que ça s véritablement passé comme ça à
17h je ne serai plus là je m'en
vais c'est alors comme dans d'autres
situations d'ailleurs où elle ni avec
une férocité
rare et elle me propose pour me prouver
sa bonne foi d'aller déposer plainte
contre ce monsieur pour harcelllement la
police de
Liège mais alors on va déposer plainte
et sa plainte quand vous la lisez c'est
pas une plte plainte légère c'est une
plainte très très violente à l'égard de
ce
monsieur voici un extrait de la plainte
que Véronique Piroton a déposé à la
police belge visant Oswald son
[Musique]
excagnon j'ai commencé à recevoir des
lettres parfumées à caractère érotique
et salass il faut préciser que ces
courriers veulent nuire à ma nouvelle
union en
une relation
extraonjugale mais moi je
l'aime et donc je ne cherchais qu'une
seule chose c'est d'être rassuré par
rapport à cela
je voulais être rassuré et donc je me
suis contenté avec un léger doute
néanmoins contenté de cette réaction ce
que je pouvais pas savoir une fois de
plus et que la police St
m'apprendra c'est que une semaineou de
semaines après elle all l'IT retirer sa
plate incroyable pour rassurer son mari
Véronique Piroton porte plainte à la
police mais ce que Bernard Westfall
ignore c'est qu'en cachette elle est
allé la retirer quelques jours plus
tard et donc je me suis pas inquiété
autre mesure de de cette affaire
j'aurais d pourtant j'aurais dû mais je
suis comme ça j'ai tendance d'être
parfois très naïf et de faire confiance
très vite sans poser beaucoup de
questions alors l'amant et conduit
aurait-il pu vouloir se venger de son
ex-maîtresse
Oswald est-il impliqué dans la mort de
Véronique on sait qu'il n'a pas quitté
le liège et on le sait parce que il a
été vérifié notamment par l'exploitation
de ces GSM les GSM d'Oswald n'ont jamais
activé d'autres bornes que des bornes
situé dans la région de liè
Oswald l'amant est donc mis hors de
cause et Bernard westwal redevient le
suspect numéro 1 les policiers ont un
suspect potentiel qu'ils ont fait qu'ils
ont fait mettre en examen par le juge et
et incarcéré mais le dossier tient pas
bien on n pas de mobile dans C
histoire alors les policiers belges vont
s'intéresser de près à la soirée du
drame le couple avait-il réservé
ensemble la chambre 602
ou alors Bernard westfal s'est-il invité
ce
soir-là il est urgent d'entendre sur ce
point le mari de
[Musique]
Véronique je suis questionné et euh je
relate ma version des
faits explique qu'ils sont allés la
veuille manger dans un petit restaurant
à stand il explique que c'est un
rendez-vous amoureux qu'il avait que
c'est un weekend qu'ils avaient projeté
de vivre ensemble et passer
ensemble qu'ils ont véritablement vécu
une romance la veille au
soir nous avons fait une réservation
dans un restaurant non loin de l'hôtel
sur la
digue la soirée était magnifique après
notre visite au restaurant nous avons eu
une soirée très romantique à
l'hôtel
selon Bernard westfal ce weekend était
l'occasion pour lui et sa femme de se
retrouver seulement c'est un courrier
retrouvé chez Véronique Piroton qui va
donner un tout autre éclairage à cette
affaire une lettre qu'elle a écrite à
son fils
Victor vior tu sais bien pas
AC appartement à cause de sa décision je
pars à la mer aujourd'hui jusqu'à
demain je suis à l'hôtel où nous allions
ensemble tu peux venir me rejoindre sans
problème je t'aime et ne te tracasse pas
je serai forte je te laisse 50 € au cas
où tu viens je te têle JE T'AIME
[Musique]
MAMAN Véronique n'aurait donc eu aucune
intention de passer un weekend en
amoureux avec Bernard
WF pire ils auraient même décidé de
rompre
définitivement alors pourquoi éta-il
ensemble à
l'hôtel les enquêteurs vont donc
reconstituer la journée du 30 octobre
2013 Véronique Piroton arrive à l'hôtel
mundo à 12h53
elle est seule et prend une chambre pour
une personne jusqu'au long demain à 15h1
elle reçoit un message de Bernard
westfal je viens te
rejoindre elle répond 40 minutes plus
tard pour quoi
faire et donc on a pu retrouver toute
une série de messages aussi bien des
messages vocaux des messages écrits qui
ont été échangé entre madame Piroton et
Bernard West dont il r vraiment très
clairement que Madame pirotonattendait
pas particulièrement Bernard ce jourl
elle est partie pour se reposer elle me
l'a proposé moi je lui ai dit que non et
puis je me
suis ravisé je lui dis je vais venir te
retrouver elle me dit pourquoi faire
parce que j'ai envie qu'on se
retrouve voilà donc on se met d'accord
elle réserve elle-même à bon restaurant
sur la digue d'ostand et qu'elle me
guide pour arriver à l'hôtel parce que
je le trouvais pas à 20h30 Bernard
Westfall arrive à h standand il se
retrouve au rest ça se passe bien il
rentre dormir à l'hôtel le lendemain
matin il réserve une deuxème nuit donc
tout a l'air de se passer de façon
normale la nuit
passe et voici ce que Bernard westfal
raconte sur la journée du lendemain donc
nous sommes rentrés dans notre chambre
après avoir pris le petit déjeuner à
l'hôtel nous avons eu
cette relation amoureuse qui s'est
poursuivie depuis la veille
[Musique]
et puis enlacer le téléphone
sonne et à partir de ce momentl je vois
une autre femme son visage change son
comportement change son attitude
change c'est moi qui répond et au moment
où je réponds j'entends au téléphone
c'est au grand méchant
[Musique]
loup je me dis bon je comprends je
comprends je dis Véronique je crois que
c'est pour toi elle prend le téléphone
elle dit c'est pas le moment c'est
vraiment pas un moment elle raccroche
rappelle il rappelle je dis monsieur
excusez-moi mais je suis le mari de de
Madame pon ah oui au revoir excusez-moi
au revoir il raccroche tout de
suite il a même pas le courage de se
présenter ni de dire elle ne vous aime
pas allez-vousen et et
pour Bernard westfal aucun doute l'homme
qui a appelé ce jour-là est celui qui
harcèle sa femme depuis des
mois et puis alors nous déciisons de
sortir vers 15h30 nous nous retrouvons
dans une taverne et nous discutons assez
longuement de cette situation
elle essaie
de de joindre son amant pour lui dire
qu'elle ne supporte plus cette agression
et ce harcèlement
à 15h39 Véronique envoie un message à
Oswald maintenant c'est
fini 3 minutes plus tard Bernard wesfal
envoie lui aussi un message à l'amant de
sa
femme moi-même je lui laisse un
sms regarde bien maintenant pauvre homme
tu vas
voir sm cette nature fait couler
beaucoup d' parce que ça voulait dire
que primunité un acte
évidemment en effet ce sms pourrait
laisser penser que Bernard westfal
jaloux aurait prévenu son rival
Oswald qu'il allait supprimer
Véronique on est à quelques heur de la
mort de Véronique Piroton c'est le mari
qui va par la suite être soupçonné de ce
meurtre qui envoie ça à Laam et c'est
vrai que pour les policiers c'est un
petit peu un petit peu le message
prémoni
c'est le le message de mise en garde ce
SMS a aussi été considéré par les
enquêteurs comme étant un indice de ce
que il y avait une
possibilité d'origine
homicidaire mais Bernard westfal a une
explication plutôt convaincante au sujet
de ce
sms ce que je voulais
dire c'est que comme Véronique avait
déposé plainte il a des Mo
plutôt mais le le lundi j'allais aller
moiême à la police déposer plainte
contre lui c'est ça que ça voulait dire
c'est évidment interpréter comme comme
un a
vu comme
si j'allais sur mon sms
annoncer que j'allais mettre fin au jour
de ma femme en je ve dire il faut
vraiment un enquêteur de bas niveau pour
penser des idiocies pareil quoi
et westfal n reste pas là durant cet
après-midi il va tenter plusieurs fois
d'appeler l'amant de sa
femme sans succès je lui laisse un
message d'ailleurs je lui dis je vous
souhaite monsieur quand même de ne pas
croiser mon chemin je vocabulaire EXM
poli à
19h45 le couple rejoint l'hôtel
mundo il s'installe au bar pour prendre
un dernier verre et c'est alors que
Véronique tente de contacter
Oswald à 5 reprises le GSM Deon Poton va
essayer de contacter alors est-ce que
SMS ou ces messages ou ces appels ont
été fait en présence de Bernard westf
comme il le dit ou pas on ne sait pas
très bien prétend que c'est devant lui
qu'elle a essayé d'appel pour lui dire
maintenant c'est fini
Oswalt Véronique Piroton serait ensuite
aller aux toilettes de l'hôtel seule
elle tente alors à diverses reprises
d'appeler son amant il ne lui répondra
[Musique]
jamais vers
20h45 le couple prend
l'ascenseur c'est la dernière fois que
Véronique Piroton est aperçue vivante
comme le montrent ces images de vidéos
surveillance
alors que s'est-il passé ensuite dans la
chambre
602 Véronique s'est-elle bel et bien
suicidé comment alors expliquer le
désordre Bernard wesfal AA encore une
explication selon lui sa femme avait
l'habitude d'entrer dans des crises
d'hystérie
spectaculair ce soir-l il explique
qu'elle se serait frappé la tête contre
les
murs puis sen serait prise à
lui je restais à distance à chaque fois
son objectif était de comme elle le
faisait elle faisait très régulièrement
son objectif était de de m'atteindre
donc c'estàdire de de Me de me frapper
ou de me griffer donc je restais à
distance sauf qu' moment donné alors que
je je la cinturis par derrière pour la
caler je jeisis une sorte de clé de
bras au moment elle s'est retourné s'est
retourné avec ses deux mains vers moi
j'ai réussi à à retirer la main droite
mais elle a touché la main gauche et
c'est là qu'on voit à côté de ma monte
les traces de des
gratur voici donc ce qui expliquerait
les égratigures que le réceptionniste de
l'hôtel avait remarqué lorsqu'il a
accompagné Bernard westfal jusqu'à sa
chambre il indiquera même au policiers
que le parlementaire saignait du
poignet mais là encore il y a quelque
chose qui ne va pas dans le récit du
mari cont tenu du délai de sécatrisation
normale de
quelqu'un s une petite Griff de cette
nature là il n'est quasiment pas
possible que cette main est saigné
pendant presque une heure donc là il y a
quelque chose qui ne va pas
manifestement c'est une laison de
défense Bernard Westfall prétend que
c'est laison de
défense c'est von Piroton qui s'est
retourné sur lui lorsqu'il voulu la
maîtriser dans sa crise
hystérie ça ne semble pas coïcid avec
les constatation méicolégal c'est tout
ce que je peux en
dire et Bernard wfal de poursuivre que
si le corps de sa femme était si
marqué cela était vraisemblablement dû à
son état
desbé elle est tombé TR fois don une
fois le nez à plat
véritablement
droit comme un sac si vous voulez quon
sur le
nez sur le nez et là elle s'est fa
vraiment très très très
mal alors Véronique Piroton s-elle ce
soirl fortement blessé parce qu'elle
avait trop bu
est-ce une bagarre conjugale qui aurait
mal
tourner ce sont les occupants des
chambres voisines qui vontenter
enquêteur il rapporte avoir entendu
beaucoup de bruit ce soir-là précisément
venant de la chambre
602 les voisins disent qu'ils ont
entendu un
bruit un bruit qui pourrait s'identifier
à une une
lutte avec un homme
qui était
fâché qui disait toujours les mêmes mots
[Musique]
comme les voisins sont étrangers ils ne
comprennent pas le le sens des mots
prononcés mais il disent il il y a un
homme qui manifestement est fâché répète
toujours la même
chose ce qui est intéressant c'est que
les voisins de la chambre juste à côté
entendent des coups sur le mur comme si
c'était le lit qui tapait sur le mur de
manière répétitive et aussi ils
entendent des pleurs de femmes des cris
de femmes femme qui cri comme un loup
dira même un des enfants la seule chose
qui est certaine c'est qu'elle a crié
très très fort et donc qu des personnes
disent avoir entendu des cris c'est
c'est c'est la vérité elle elle a crié
très très fort comme à l'occasion de de
chaque crise et puis elle se calme
soudain et et puis on nentend plus
rien une fois la crise passée Bernard
westfal raconte qu'il a
décidé de se
coucher et j'ai fermé les yeux en
espérant que la situation se calme
définitivement il y a eu quelques
murmures quelques mots euh
quelques comment
dirais-je quelques quelques éléments peu
sympathiques mais dont j'avais même
pasun écoute précise parce que il était
déjà un peu éloigné du du lit en
rentrant dans la salle de bain moi j'ai
pas demandé mon reste je suis aller me
coucher
et c'est tout c'est tout le
parlementaire explique qu'ensuite il
s'est endormi est-ce que j'ai dormis 30
minutes 40 minutes 50 minutes 27 minutes
je ne sais
pas je me réveil je cherche après je
vais dans la salle de bain vous
connaissez la suite je la trouve à
mointier nue avec un sachet plastique
qu'est-ce que je fais je lui enlève je
lu fais un massage cardiaque je je lui
scoue d'abord le cou je l'embrasse je
lui fais du bouche à bouche je lui fais
un massage cardiaque assez maladroit je
reconnais euh quand j'ai vu comment ça
s'est passa après
euh je suis dans un
état indescriptible si vous voulez ça
veut dire que je suis dans dans
l'incapacité
de hurler je ne sais
plus ce soir-là les choses se seraient
donc déroul ainsi selon le seul témoin
de la
[Musique]
scène mais les résultats des expertises
ADN faites dans la chambre
tombent et ils mettent à mal la version
du
parlementaire
le premier élément qui étonne les
experts c'est ce fameux sachet en
plastique que Bernard westfal dit avoir
trouvé posé sur le visage de son
épouse c'est un sa chamb si très fin qui
en plus de ça était troué Bernard
Westfall a dit dans ses premières
auditions qu'il était persuadé que son
épouse s'était suicidée à l'aide de ce
sachet en plastique en fait dans la
manière dont ce sachet en plastique posé
sur le visage de Poton il évidemment
absolument impossible qu'elle se suicide
de cette manière lorsque vous vous
étouffez avec quelque chose qui obstruit
V VO nasale et votre bouche vous perdez
connaissance vos muscle se relâche et
donc ce que vous avez sur le visage
inévitablement doit tomber par terre il
n aucune chance qu'il retombe pile
exactement l'endroit où vous l'avez
laissé on peut pas expliquer la présence
de ce sachet sur la bouche de la victime
telle que Bernard le décrit lui-même et
ce n'est pas tout les experts notent une
trace de fond de teint laissée sur le
bas de l'armoire de la chambre
d'hôtel une trace dont personne ne peut
expliquer la
provenance les experts disent simplement
qu'il s'agit bien du maquillage de
Véronique Piroton et que c'est une trace
de frottement sur le bas d'armoire
Bernard westfal n'a pas d'explication
sur cette sur cette trace parce que euh
lorsqu'il euh lors de laonstitution va
mimer les chutes de Véronique Piroton à
aucun moment elle ne tombe à proximité
de cette armoire et donc à aucun moment
elle ne pourrait avoir laissé une trace
sur
l'armoire laquelle armoire se situe
entre la chambre et la salle de
bain je ne l'explique pas
euh je n'en sais rien à vrai dire il y a
quelques éléments comme cela euh qui
sont vraiment euh permettez-moi
uneexpression mais anecdotique même pas
troublant est-ce que en tombant elle est
elle s'est cogné en je dis elle a frotté
l'armoire ou pas ça je ne suis vous le
dire complètement mais tout ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'elle est bien
tombé trois fois la seule explication
plausible est que cette trace aurait été
faite aurait été laissée par Véronique
Piroton par le corps de Véronique
Piroton qu'on aurait pu traîner devant C
armoire qui se trouve juste devant
l'entrée de la salle
deain le corps de Véronique Piroton
aurait-il été traîné de la chambre à la
salle de bain rien ne permet de le
prouver et les experts relèvent un
dernier élément troublant sur le visage
de Véronique on retrouve 14 fibres de
l'oreiller sur lequel Bernard westfal 1
endormis ce sont des fibres qui sont
extrêmement particulières ce sont des
fibres qui ne collent pas à la peau
elles adèrent d'autant moins la peau
humaine que le visage est
maquillé il faut partir d'un constat
c'est que nous avons Véronique et moi
passé une bonne partie de la journée sur
ses oreillers et sur le mien je vais pas
non plus vous raconter une relation
amoureuse euh simplement elle a eu
contact avec ce
coussin pendant une longue
période seulement cette version ne
convain pas l'avocat général et cela
pour une raison toute
simple manifestement cet oreiller éta en
contact sel ses experts de manière très
intense avec le visage de Véronique
peroton très peu de temps avant le décès
de
celle-ci très peu de temps parce que les
quantités de fibres que l'on découvre
sous le visage de Feron Panton sont
significativement
importante alors contact très intense
c'est pas de dormir dessus et c'est même
pas je dirais d'avoir la tête enfoncée
dans l'oreiller profondément à un moment
donné non il faut véritablement qu'il y
a une pression qui sont exercé sur cet
oreiller et sur le visage pour qu'il y
ait une telle impréation de
fibres plus de 9 mois après sa mise en
détention Bernard wesfal est remis en
liberté le parquet belge estime qu'il ne
représente pas de danger pour la société
mais l'homme politique reste mis en
examen pour le meurtre de son
épouse c'est un moment quand même assez
extraordinaire parce que vous retrouvez
le l'air libre la liberté vos amis votre
famille vos enfants et cetera et donc ça
prend une
dimension
un vraisemblable parce qu' moment donné
je pensais que je sortirai
jamais je pensais qu' qu' qu'il me
lâcherait jamais et qu'il avaient décidé
véritablement avoir ma peau point
final pour la famille de Véronique
Piroton cette libération est
littéralement
scandaleuse on ne s'y attendait pas du
tout à ce qu'il soit
libéré
et c'est vrai que ça nous a fait un choc
épouvantable parce qu'on s'est dit on va
on va pouvoir le rencontrer n'importe où
en ville
quoi d'ailleurs moi je l'ai rencontré
avec avec son fils qui se promenait he
je me suis dit toi tu as ton fils tu te
promènes avec ton fils Victor il ne
revra jamais sa
[Musique]
maman le 19 septembre 2016 le procès de
Bernard westfal s'ouvre devant la Cour
d'Assise du ho à
monce durant cette audience un élément
capital va être livré au juré une
conversation téléphonique entre
Véronique Piroton et Oswald son
amant une discussion qui date du 29
octobre 2013 la veille de la mort de la
quadragéè par rapport à toi donc il a
essayé de me de me jeter sur le li que
je mon l alors il m'a pris par les
blign mais fort quo et
et assulté de tout mag
gross tout ce que tu peux imaginer quoi
oui ouais et il voulait pas sortir de ma
chambre moi jeis pas le en finalement je
le mettre dehors et je la
oui donc vous en êtes venu au main alors
bah oui oui en tout cas oui
ou parce que il a de la force l'air de
rien faut pas
croire cette communication téléphonique
est particulièrement accablante en ce
qui concerne Bernard westfal dans ses
relations avec Madame Piroton parce que
elle dit clairement que ce n'est plus
possible qu'ils ont décidé de déménager
elle explique aussi que Bernard Westfall
est violent que lorsqu'il Abu ne se
contrôle pas et que les choses é arrivé
à un
point final il nétait plus possible pour
elle de recommencer une vie de continuer
à vivre avec lui que c'est une des un
des motifs pour lequel elle partait à la
mer pour nous c'est émouvant d'entendre
sa
voix forcément puis ça ne fait que
confirmer ce que nous on savait c'est
que elle voulait se séparer puisque dans
le message elle est
clairire elle dit qu'elle va au stand
qu'elle qu'elle qu'elle va séparer que
c'est pour
séparation mais face au président de la
cour Bernard westfal contreattaque et se
défend bec et
ongle mais évidemment ça me fait mal
d'entendre d'entendre cet enregistrement
de cet homme qui manifestement cherche à
lui faire dire des choses qui sont
fausses je dis monsieur le Président je
suis obligé de le dire mon épouse tenait
des discours dimétralement osé à l'un et
aux
autres c'est que Véronique breton pour
avir de
discours et je pense que c'est toute
l'ambiguité de cette femme et de ce
dossier c'est toute l'ambigué du
comportement de vonique
Peron le proc se concentre alors sur une
question les causes de la mort de
Véronique les experts légistes mandatés
par la défense de Bernard westfal sont
entendus pour eux il n'est pas possible
de prouver que vonque Piroton a été
battu puis
étouffé ils avanceent que c'est le
mélange alcool médicament qui aurait pu
la
tuer la défense a très
intelligemment centrer le débat sur le
fait qu'il y avait une autre cause
possible à la
mort et finalement ils arrivent à faire
dire aux experts que une personne
lambda avec telle dose de médicament et
telle dose
de d'alcool bien il n'est pas impossible
il n'est pas inenvisageable qu'elle
décède mais ce que disent les experts
c'est oui mais ça n'explique pas tout le
reste il y a tout le
reste du côté des parties civiles le
doute ne serait pas permis Bernard
Westfall aurait bien tué Véronique
Piroton notre hypothèse était que la
scène a eu lieu en deux fois qui a une
première scène sur le lit o où il y
aurait probablement une tentative
d'étouffement avec le coussin et que
ensuite Véronique Piroton se serait
échappé de la pression qui est mise sur
elle vraisemblablement heurant l'armoire
ce qui expliquerait la trace de
maquillage et puis que Bernard Westfall
l'aurait rattrapé au niveau de la salle
de bain et aurait apposé le sachet de
plastique sur son
visage l'avocat général a lui aussi
plaidé la culpabilité de l'homme
politique à mon hypothèse c'est que si
c'est une hystérie alu bernardfall a
étouffé sa compagne dans un excès de
rage de colère tout Simp
ement Bernard westf n'en pouvait plus la
situation qu'il vivait avec vique peton
je pense qu'il a fait des efforts sur
toute une série de choses il a dû se
rendre compte il le savait que sa femme
lui mentait et qu'elle menait sans doute
véritable lait double jeu depuis des
mois et des mois et c'est un crime d'un
homme excédé j'ai défendu la thèse d'un
homme du crime commis par un homme qui é
[Musique]
excédé
le 6 octobre 2016 les jurés rendent leur
verdict après 3 semaines de débat vu la
réponse du jury à la question posée par
le président de la cour d'assis sur le
fait mis à charge de westfal Bernard
Marcel Léon né à Warem le 25 septembre
1958 58 ans à la question principale de
culpabilité non
vu les articles taisez-vous s'il vous
plaît je ne parviens pas totalement à
réaliser parce que je me dis ce que j'ai
bien compris ce n'est que quand mes
avocats me touchent et cetera que je me
dis que je vois les larmes aux yeux de
mes avocat je me dis mais oui c'est
ça et donc là c'était vraiment en grand
soulagement mais Don j'ai pas totalement
pu profiter parce que c'est un imange
gâi et j'ai j'ai expliqué qui qui avait
pas de de quoi du tout paroiser après
cette libération des l'instant où le mal
était fait et si Bernard westfal ne
pavoiss pas comme il dit c'est parce
qu'il a été acquitté certes mais au
bénéfice du
doute Jourie la cassise a considéré que
la cause du décès n'étant pas absolument
certaine il fallait quitter Berna westf
tout en
disant bon qu'il y a toute une sériement
troublant la position du corps
l'existence et l'emplacement du schant
en
plastique la présence de nombreuses
hématomes et des lésions relev leur de
l'autopsie les bruits entendus selon
déclarations des voisins de chambre
l'attitude de
l'accusé juste après le drame et ce
voilà c'est un acquitement au bénéfice
du
doute pour la famille de Véronique
Piroton cette décision est incompréhens
on se dit que de toute façon il n'était
que de dans la chambre ça ne pouvait
être que lui
puisque les résultats disait que c'était
par un ti
donc pour nous ça a été
clair que c'est injuste c'est
[Musique]
tout
aujourd'hui Bernard westfal mène une vie
normale
ou presque
je dois vivre avec ça avec l'idée que
des gens pensent quand même que j'aurais
pu commettre cet acte et donc il y aura
toujours un partage entre ceux qui
pensent que j'étais victime d'un
acharnement judiciaire et que j'étais
profondément innocent et ce qui pensent
que il n'est pas impossible quand même
que je sois responsable de cet acte ne
me demandez pas de de poser un jugement
sur la décision judiciaire parce que moi
je pense que la vérité judiciaire ou si
imparfaite soit elle il n'y en a pas
d'autres je peux vous dire aujourd'hui
dans les
yeux non je n'ai pas tué Véronique
Piroton 4 ans après le décès de
Véronique Piroton il n'y a toujours pas
de certitude sur les causes de sa mort
et comme ultime recours sa famille
souhaite maintenant aller devant la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme
afin d'obtenir plus de
répones Bernard westfal lui songe à
reprendre sa carrière
[Musique]
politique